zoom out for a second if you're the pfl
one thing they've been very good at is
raising money if they're going to sign
Francis it would actually make all the
sense in the world to try and buy
Bellator where now you have access to
Ryan Bader now you have access to a
potential series of other heavyweight
opponents how exciting all that is to
you at this moment I don't know let's
say that they get Francis and they're
able to buy a controlling share of
Bellator and let's say merge
organizations you don't exactly buy the
world in terms of bringing them over for
heavyweight fights for Francis on
pay-per-view but now you have created a
very clear destination for any free
agent it is only one place you're going
to go to for heavyweight four
heavyweight at that point now these are
a lot of ifs to me what is happening
behind the scenes is pfl is pushing all
their chips in the middle and saying
let's go be the real unequivocal number
two in the sport we'll see if they can
do it